this is the british museum
it's the world's largest world history
museum and it draws
millions of visitors every year inside
it holds more than eight million
cultural and historical artifacts
from all over the world which cover 2
million years of human history
if you follow the museum's recommended
list of don't miss
items you'll see its star pieces like
this easter island sculpture that's
about a thousand years old
or this bronze sculpture of the hindu
god shiva
[Music]
but there's a problem hidden in the
museum and we can see an example of it
along this route
out of those 12 pieces nearly half have
disputed ownership
the british museum claims those pieces
belong there
on display for the world to see but in
recent years
many have been fighting to get them back
to where they came from
the list of disputed museum treasures
keeps on growing should cultural
artifacts return to their home countries
or be left in western museums the
subject of intense debate as to who
should now own them
let's start with some context in the
late 1600s the british empire began
expanding across several continents it
became the largest empire in history
controlling about a quarter of the
world's land and population
during its centuries-long role the
empire took precious resources and
wealth
from countries all over the world
including cultural and historical
artifacts
many of which ended up here in the
british museum
which was founded in 1753 and kept
growing
to accommodate all the new pieces in its
collection
lots of the items in the museum were
legally acquired
and are completely undisputed like this
one a two thousand year old roman base
sold to the museum by a duke in 1945.
the problem is with the pieces that are
disputed
like the first item you see as soon as
you walk in
the rosetta stone taken by british
troops from the french
in what is now egypt or further in
the parthenon sculptures removed from
the acropolis in athens by a british
lord and sent to the british museum
or over here on the floor dedicated to
african art
the benin bronzes some of the most
contentious items
in the museum the benin bronzes are
kind of hard to categorize because they
include such a huge range of items
from engraved ivory tusks to brass
sculptures
to plaques but they were all produced
here in the kingdom of benin in
present-day nigeria
this wealthy and industrious kingdom
produced thousands of objects and art
pieces
starting in the 1500s a lot of the items
adorned palace walls and were used for
religious rituals
but they weren't just decorative there
were visual archives
of the kingdom in a society that did not
develop
a written script as we know
them that's professor chika okekeyagulu
an art historian and professor from
nigeria who teaches at princeton
university
they told their history how they
narrated
the histories of kingship of the kingdom
its political and social life
but in 1897 benin would lose
thousands of these cultural pieces
at the time european colonial powers
were expanding south
in what was called the scramble for
africa they split up the continent into
spheres of influence for financial
exploitation
all these pink areas were the british
ones benin
over here was in britain's sphere of
influence but the kingdom
didn't comply with britain's trade
demands and in january of 1897
it led to what was called the benin
disaster where benin guards killed seven
british emissaries
plus their many guides and servants in
response
1 200 british troops embarked on a
mission called the benin
punitive expedition the british wanted
revenge
but the mission was about more than just
that
there were reports of these vast
treasures
in the palace of the king of the name
and that if they could retrieve these
treasures
sales from it could offset the cost
of the invasion this was all
well planned and so the punitive
expedition
in other words was also an economic
enterprise
the british soldiers armed with machine
guns conquered the city and burned it to
the ground
but not before carefully taking
thousands of artifacts
they piled them up neatly photographed
them and
even labeled them loot this photo taken
at the benin palace
after the raid shows soldiers with the
dismantled plaques that were brought to
the british museum
and sold all over the world
and after hundreds of years the once
prosperous kingdom
was gone the region fell under full
british colonial control
until 1960 when nigeria including the
city of benin
gained independence but even though they
were finally free
their historical artifacts were still
spread all over the world
locked up in western institutions like
the leipzig museum
of ethnology in germany and the que
brandle museum
in paris and of course the british
museum
[Music]
1995 in london
that was my first time of seeing an
original
uh ancient benin
artwork was yes at the british museum
being in the presence of these
magnificent
objects and knowing that i had to travel
all the way from nigeria
to see for the first time in these
objects it was a mixture of
pride in the achievement of these
ancient artists and and mixed with a
sense of
loss at what could have been if
i only had to travel a few hundred miles
but at this point you're limited to
those uh privileged like me
who could get a visa to travel all the
way from nigeria to england
um to encounter these objects
most nigerians will never see them
[Music]
in march 2000 benin's royal family tried
to change that
they officially requested all cultural
property
illegally taken be returned to the
rightful owner but
for the most part the british museum has
ignored any requests
the museum is restricted by a government
act that prevents it from returning
objects
but it has also made its stance clear in
july of 2020 the british museum told vox
we don't restitute but we are absolutely
committed to lending as widely as
possible
including to nigeria the museum's
foundational value resides in its
breadth
scale complexity and unity and as such
is a true library of the world
chica doesn't see it that way the
british museum still behaves like a
colonial museum
you cannot claim to be
an encyclopedic collector of stolen
objects but some are starting to reckon
with this history
in 2014 the grandson of this british
soldier from the 1897 benin punitive
expedition
returned these two items he had
inherited to the benin royal family
and in 2007 the benin dialogue group was
formed
western museums that hold the bronzes
and nigerian government representatives
have been discussing potential solutions
ever since but as of today
none of the bronzes have been returned
but this
is just one story this legacy is
bigger than the bannon bronzes there are
hundreds of contested items in the
british museum
with their own rich histories and with
original owners trying to retrieve them
but the problem is even bigger than the
british museum
it's a legacy of centuries of colonial
power that repeats itself again
and again with different artifacts in
different museums
because these requests aren't just about
items
they are also about cultural and
historical identity
and who gets to own it this is a long
term project it may
last beyond my own lifetime
but the point is that it's now
to start that process we cannot wait any
longer
for a next generation to even begin the
necessary
task and project of cultural
[Music]
reconstitution
[Music]
you